[Music]
we are talking 2018 and everything in
between look at that rhyme right there
we can't recap this year without talking
about BTS I know one of your favorites
another big year for my favorite blue
band it was such a major year for the
group and today we're revisiting some of
their biggest moments of 2018 starting
with that video you guys just saw me
brush the in my feelings dance challenge
but that wasn't the only dance challenge
that they tackled this year who can
forget when Jimmy Fallon got them to do
the fortnight challenge on The Tonight
Show which I will say is very tough
dance to try to master I know and like
see things I saw this for the very first
time but check this out you guys here we
go that's Jade right there just crushing
it you know in for tonight of course was
one of the biggest video games in 2018
yen one of the biggest music groups of
the year just nailing that routine I'm
still trying to learn that one all right
number two those guys they also broke
Taylor Swift's record on YouTube for the
most views in the first 24 hours for a
music video on YouTube within 24 hours
of the release of Idol the music video
had already amassed more than 45 million
views and can you blame them beating
beating Taylor Swift look what you made
me do which accumulated only forty three
point two million in its first tour
exactly uh sadly they didn't keep that
one spot for too long they were recently
knocked off the top spot by ariana
grande for of course but thank you next
video but you know Idol still is gonna
be one of those music videos from BTS
we're gonna be talking about for a very
long time and then another major moment
for them was the collaboration with
Nicki Minaj their remix
just when I thought Idol was the pop
then they got Nicki Minaj on the remix
and that has been on heavy rotation and
even shot a video with her a version of
Idol with Nicki Minaj as well that was
in September the month after the release
of the first scene and then more huge
collaborations another big moment for
them collaborating with Steve Aoki
firaon wasted on me and you actually you
talked to them about it exactly it's not
the first time the club was Steve Aoki
but Steve has been
dying he told me to get back in the
studio with them though a song is wasted
on me actually talked to him half the
Latin Grammys about when we can expect
the music video with the guys here's
what using the video all the video is
gonna be epic yeah it's gonna its
cultural is it it's gonna be a big one a
big one how would you describe it in one
word I uh cultural yeah cuz I don't want
to give away too much you know I really
feel like it's gonna be a special video
it's the most my most special video that
I've ever been part of and put together
so I'm very excited about it you know I
would make the argument that in 2017
they start bubbling up right and now
everybody wants to comment yes Steve's
been lucky to do it a couple times now
but you know the year ended with their
very first Grammy nomination which is
pretty major then we got one nomination
it was in a technical category for best
recording package but more than anything
this is just a major moment of inclusion
and honestly appreciation for kpop and
South Korea's breakout year and their
breakout artist explains to everyone
know why you know best recording package
like the importance of it because it's
it honors you know the team productively
right it's the whole team right and it's
a it's about bringing like this I can
mention this visibility to k-pop artists
on I wish they crack the pop categories
I really do but this nomination is
shared with everyone who had a hand in
the recording package in the BTS trilogy
right here you seal of yourself which I
mean literally has broken records all
year long and so now they get an
invitation to the biggest night of music
what do you hope is next cuz obviously
you are a huge BTS fan you just visited
Seoul right what do you hope is next for
them what do you think is next net you
know I know that uh early on when I
first interviewed them I asked whether
or not they would do in English language
album but as I learned from the fans
they're not looking for that right so I
what I'm hoping for instead is more
amazing amazing collaborations you know
some big artists and as we know they
recently teased may be a possible edge
here in collaboration so maybe we have
that to look forward to
[Music]
[Applause]